Hua Hai
[Music]
Hello Hello Guidelines Friends Many The Founder
of Road Tax Basically this is the YouTube channel
on which we are going to talk about things
which are going to be related
to computer science to artificial intelligence
machine learning and ethical hacking so  Now we have
a new video on our YouTube channel
which is on Hydration Tool in which we are
using our OpenCV and Half Inch data
to create eye protection for you.
Change directions
while sleeping. Basically, we have a new YouTube channel
so more support.
Share it as much as possible with your friends and
like the events thanks to the fact
that you have reached a higher level.